let's see if we can use everything we
know about differentiation and
connectivity and maximum and minimum
points and inflection points to actually
graph a function without using a
graphing calculator so let's say our
function let's say that f of X is equal
to 3x to the fourth minus minus 4x to
the 3rd plus 2 and of course you could
always graph a function just by trying
out a bunch of points but we want to
really focus on the the points that are
interesting to us and then just to get
the general shape of the function
especially we want to focus on the
things that we can take out from this
function using our calculus toolkit or
our derivative toolkit so the first
thing we probably want to do is figure
out the critical points we want to
figure out I'll write it here critical
critical points and just as a refresher
of what critical point means it's the
point where F where the derivative of f
of X is 0 so critical points are f prime
of X is either equal to 0 or it's
undefined or if undefined this function
looks differentiable everywhere so the
critical points that we worried about
are probably well I can tell you they're
definitely just the points where F prime
of X are going to be equal to 0 this
this this derivative F prime of X is
going to actually be defined over the
entire domain so let's actually write
down the derivative right now so the
derivative of this F prime F prime of X
this is pretty straightforward the
derivative of 3x to the 4th 4 times 3 is
12 12x to the it will just decrement the
4 by 1/3 right you just multiply times
the exponent and then decrease the new
exponent by 1 minus 3 times 4 is 12
times X to the 1 less than 3 is 2 and
then the derivative of a constant the
slope of a constant you can almost
imagine is zero it's not changing a
constant by definition isn't changing so
that's F prime of X so let's figure out
the critical points the critical points
are where this thing is
either going to be equal to zero or it's
undefined now I could look over the
entire domain of real numbers and this
thing is defined pretty much anywhere I
could put any number here and it's not
going to blow up it's going to give me
an answer to what the function is so
that it's defined everywhere so let's
just figure out where it's equal to zero
so f prime of x is equal to zero so
let's solve which X is so let's solve
well I don't have to rewrite that I just
wrote that let's solve for whether this
is equal to zero and I'll do it in the
same color so 12 X to the third minus 12
x squared is equal is equal to zero and
so let's see what we can do what can we
do to solve this well we could factor
out a 12x so if we factor out a 12x then
this term becomes just X and then
actually let's look factor out a 12x
squared we factor out a 12x squared if
we divide both of these by 12x squared
this term just becomes an X and then
minus 12x squared divided by 12x squared
is just 1 is equal to 0 I just rewrote
this top thing like this you could go
the other way if I multiply distributed
this 12x squared times this entire
quantity you would get my derivative
right there so the reason why I did that
is because to solve for 0 or if I want
all of the X's that that make this
equation equal to 0 we now have I now
have written it in a form where I'm
multiplying one thing by another thing
and in order for this to be zero one or
both of these things must be equal to 0
so 12x squared or equal to 0 which means
that X is equal to 0 will make this
quantity equal 0 and then the other
thing that would make this quantity 0 is
if X minus 1 is equal to 0 so X minus 1
is equal to 0 when X is equal to 1 so
these are our two critical points
our two critical points or X is equal to
0 and X is equal to 1 and remember those
are just the points where our first
derivative is equal to 0 where the where
the slope is 0 they might be maximum
points they might be minimum points they
might be in flat
points we don't know they might be you
know this was a constant function they
could just be anything so we really
can't say a lot about them just yet
there but they are points of interest I
guess that's all we can say that they
are definitely points of interest but
let's keep going and let's try to
understand the concavity and maybe we
can get a better sense of this graph so
let's let's figure out the second
derivative so the second I'll do that in
let me do it in this orange color so the
second derivative of my function f let's
see 3 times 12 is 36 x squared minus 24x
so let's see well there's a couple of
things we can do now that we know the
second derivative we can answer the
question is my graph concave upwards or
downwards at either of these points so
let's figure out what at either of these
critical points and it'll all fit
together remember if it's concave
upwards then we're kind of in a u-shape
if it's concave downwards then we're in
a in a kind of upside-down U shape so F
prime prime our second derivative at X
is equal to 0 is equal to what it's
equal to 36 0 squared minus 24 times 0
so that's just 0 so f prime prime so
it's just equal to 0 so we're in either
concave upwards nor concave downwards
here it might be a transition point it
may not if it is a transition point then
we're dealing with an inflection point
we're not sure yet now let's see what F
prime prime or a second derivative
evaluated it one is so that's 36 times 1
let me write it down that's equal to 36
times 1 squared which is just 36 minus
24 minus 24 times 1 so 36 minus 24 so
it's equal to 12 so this is positive our
second derivative is positive here it's
equal to 12 which means our first driven
creasing the rate of change of our slope
is positive here so this at this point
right here we are concave upwards
upwards which tells me that this is
probably a minimum point right the slope
is 0 here but we are concave upwards at
the
points oh that's interesting so let's
see if there are any other potential
inflection points here we already know
that this is this is a potential
inflection point let me circle it in red
it's a potential inflection point we
don't know whether our function actually
transitions at that point we'll have to
experiment a little bit to see if that's
really the case but let's see if there
are any other inflection points so to
figure that or potential inflection
points so let's see if this equals zero
anywhere else so 36 x squared minus 24 X
is equal to zero let's solve for X let
us factor out a well you can factor our
12 X 12 X times 3x right 3x times 12x is
36 x squared minus 2 is equal to 0 so
this is these two are equivalent
expressions if you multiply this out
you'll get this thing up here so this
thing is going to be equal to 0 either
of 12x is equal to 0 so 12 X is equal to
0 that gives us X is equal to 0 so x
equals 0 this thing equals 0 so the
second the second derivative is 0 then
we already knew that because we tested
that number out or this thing if this
expression was 0 then the entire second
derivative would also be 0 so let's
write that so 3x minus 2 is equal to 0
3x is equal to 2
just adding 2 to both sides 3x is equal
to 2/3 so this is another interesting
point that we haven't really hit upon
before that might be an inflection point
the reason why I say it might be is
because the second derivative is
definitely 0 here you put 2/3 here
you're going to get 0 and what we have
to do is see whether the second
derivative is positive or negative on
either sides of of 2/3 and we already
have a sense of that I mean we could try
out a couple of numbers we know that you
know if we take X's if we say that X is
greater than 2/3 let me scroll down a
little bit so so if we have some space
so let's see what happens when X is
greater than 2/3 X is greater than 2/3
what is f prime of X so let's see all
right sorry what is f prime prime what
is the second derivative
so let's try out a value that's pretty
close just to get a sense of things just
to get a sense of things so let me
rewrite it F prime prime of X is equal
to let me write it like this I mean I
could write it like this but this might
be easier to deal with it's equal to 12x
times 3x minus 2 so if X is greater than
two-thirds this term right here is going
to be positive that's definitely you
know any it's any positive number times
12 is going to be positive but what
about this term right here three times
two-thirds minus two is exactly zero
right that's two minus two but anything
larger than that three times you know if
I had to point one thirds right so if
here this is going to be a positive
quantity any value of x greater than
two-thirds will make this thing right
here positive right this thing is also
going to be positive so that means that
when X is greater than two-thirds that
tells us that the second derivative is
positive it is greater than zero so in
our domain as long as X is larger than
two-thirds we are concave upwards and we
saw that here at F at X is equal to one
we were concave upwards but what about X
being less than two-thirds so when X is
less than 2/3 let me write it let me
scroll down a little bit when X is less
than 2/3 what's going on I'll rewrite it
F prime prime of X second derivative 12x
times 3x minus 2 well if we go you know
really far less we're going to get a
negative number here and this might be
neighbor but let's see if we just could
really like you know right below
two-thirds when we're still in the
positive domain so you know if this was
like 1.9 thirds which is you know
mixture of a decimal in a fraction or
even one-third this thing is still going
to be positive right below two-thirds
this thing is still going to be positive
we're going to be multiplying 12 by a
positive number but what's going to be
going on what's going on right here
what's going on right here at two-thirds
we're exactly zero but as you go is
anything less than two-thirds three
times one-third is only one one minus
two you're going to get negative numbers
so when X is less than 2/3 this
thing right here is going to be negative
so the second derivative if X is less
than two-thirds the second derivative
right right to the left or right when
you go less than two-thirds the second
derivative of X is less than zero now
the fact that we have this transition
from when we're less than two-thirds we
have a negative second derivative and
when we're greater than two-thirds we
have a positive second derivative that
tells us that this indeed is an
inflection point that X is equal to
two-thirds is definitely an inflection
point for our regional function up here
now we have one more candidate
inflection point and then we're ready to
graph then you know once you know all
the inflection points in the maximum
minimum you are ready to graph the
function so let's see if X is equal to
zero is an inflection point we know that
the second derivative is zero at zero
but what happens above and below the
second derivative so let's let me do our
little test here so when X is let me
draw a line so I don't so we don't get
confused with all of the stuff that I
wrote here so when X is greater than
zero what's happening the second
derivative remember the second
derivative was equal to 12x times 3x
minus two I like writing it this way
because you've kind of decomposed it
into two linear expressions and you can
see whether each of them are positive or
negative so if X is greater than zero
this thing right here is definitely
going to be positive and then this thing
right here right when you go right above
X is greater than zero so we have to
make sure to be very close to this
number right so this number is like
point let's say it's point one right so
you know you're right above zero
so this is going to be true for all of X
greater than zero we just want to test
exactly what happens right when we go
right above zero so this was point one
you would have 0.3 0.3 minus 2 that
would be a negative number right so
right as X goes right above zero this
thing right here is negative so as X is
greater than 0 you will have your second
derivative is going to be less than 0
you're concave downwards which makes
sense because we're at some point we're
going to be hitting a train
remember where we were concave downwards
before we got to two-thirds right so
this is consistent from zero to
two-thirds we are concave downwards and
then at two-thirds we become concave
upwards now let's see what happens when
X what X is right less than when X is
just barely just barely less than zero
so once again F Prime the second
derivative of X is equal to 12x times 3x
minus 2 well right if you know if X was
minus 0.1 or minus 0.0001 no matter what
this thing is going to be negative this
expression right here is going to be
negative the 12x right you have some
negative value here times 12 it's going
to be negative and then what's this
going to be well three times minus 0.1
is going to be minus 0.3 minus 2 is
minus two point three you're definitely
going to have a negative this value
right here is going to be negative and
then when you subtract from a negative
it's definitely going to be negative so
that is also going to be negative but if
you multiply a negative times a negative
you're gonna get a positive so actually
right below X is less than 0 the second
derivative is positive the second
derivative is positive now this one
might have been a little bit confusing
but we've we should now have the payoff
we now have the payoff we have all of
the interesting things going on we know
that it X is equal to 1 we know that X
is equal to 1 let me write it over here
and that way we figured out at X is
equal to 1 the slope is 0 so f prime
prime is sorry let me write it this way
I should have said we know that the
slope is zero slope is equal to 0 and we
figured that out because the first
derivative was 0 this was a critical
point and we know that we're dealing
with the the function is concave upwards
at this point and that tells us that
this is going to be a minimum point so
what is f of and we should actually get
the coordinates so we can actually graph
it that was the whole point of this
video so and F of 1 is equal to what F
of 1 let's go back to our original
function is 3 times 1
right one to the fourth is just 1 3
times 1 minus 4 plus 2 right so 4 times
so it's it's it's well 3 times 1 minus 4
times 1 which is minus 1 plus 2 well
that's just a positive 1 so f of 1 is 1
and then we know that X is equal to 0 we
also figured out that the slope is equal
to 0 but we figured out that this was an
inflection point right the the
connectivity switches before and after
so this is an inflection point
inflection point and we are concave
below 0 below 0 so when X is less than 0
we are upwards we are upwards our second
derivative is positive and when X is
greater than 0 we are downwards we are
concave downwards right above not for
all of the domain X and 0 just right
above 0 downwards and then what is f of
0 just so we know we want to graph that
point F of 0
let's see F of 0 this is easy 3 times 0
minus 4 times 0 plus 2 well that's just
2 f of 0 is 2 and then finally we got
the point X is equal to 2/3 X is equal
to let me do that in another color we
had the point X is equal to 2/3 we
figured out that this was a inflection
point the slope isn't necessarily lower
the slope definitely isn't 0 there
because it wasn't one of the critical
points and we know that we are downwards
we know that when X is less than 2/3 or
right lessons 2/3 we are concave
downwards and when X is greater than 2/3
we saw it up here when X was greater
than 2/3 right up here
we were concave upwards the second
derivative was positive we were upwards
and we could actually figure out what's
F of 2/3 that's actually a little bit
complicated we don't even have to figure
that I don't think to graph I think we
could do a pretty good job of graphing
it
just with what we know right now so
that's our takeaways let me do a rough
graph let's see so let me do my axes
just like that so let's see we're going
to want to graph the point zero two so
let's say that the point zero two so
this is X is equal to zero and we go up
one two so this is the point zero two
maybe I'll do it in that color the color
I was using so that's this color so
that's that point right there then we
have the point X we have F of one which
is the point 1 1 right so this point
right here is will go up 1 so that's the
point 1 1 this was the point 0 2 and
then we have the X is equal to 2/3 which
is our inflection point so when X is 2/3
we don't know exactly what number F of
2/3 is might be here someplace let's say
F of 2/3 is right there so that's the
point 2/3 and then whatever F of 2/3 is
it looks like it's going to be 1 point
something F of 2/3 you could calculate
it if you like you just have to
substitute back in the function but
we're ready to graph this we're ready to
graph this thing so we know that it X is
equal to 1 the slope is 0 we know that
the slope is 0 it's flat here and we
know it's concave upwards so we're
dealing it looks like this it looks like
that over that interval we're concave
upwards and we know we're concave
upwards from X is equal to 2/3 and on
right front let me do it in that color
we knew X you 2/3 and on we're concave
upwards and so that's why I was able to
draw this u-shape now we know that when
X is less than 2/3 and greater than 0
we're concave downwards so the graph
would look something like this over this
interval will be concave downwards let
me draw it nicely over this interval the
slope is decreasing and you could see it
if you keep drawing tangent lines it's
flattish there it gets negative more
negative more negative more in it until
the inflection point and then it starts
increasing again because we go back to
concave upwards and then finally the
last interval is below 0 and we know
below 0 when X is less than 0 we're
concave upwards so the graph looks like
this
well graph looks like that and we also
know that X is equal to zero was a
critical point the slope was zero so
this graph is actually flat right there
- so this is an inflection point where
the slope was also zero so this is our
final graph we're done after all that
work we were able to use our calculus
skills and our knowledge of inflection
points and concavity and transitions and
concavity to actually graph this fairly
fairly hairy looking graph but this this
should be kind of what it looks like if
you graph it on your calculator